foreign
thanks to anime becoming more mainstream
more and more people have become more
open and accepting of the medium and
that's allowed them to enjoy this form
of entertainment that's touched so many
people in different ways you know back
in my younger days you'd be hard-pressed
to find a lot of people who treated
anime seriously brushing them off as
just cartoons but it can actually be
such a powerful medium in so many ways
that's why for today I want to go a
little bit edgier than the usual PG-13
content how about pushing the list to 20
for today and talking about what I think
on my top 20 action anime that are more
mature I'm talking about something that
could if it hasn't already passes are
rated or while examining themes that may
be quite deep owing to the strength of
anime as a storytelling medium keep in
mind though I'm not going to be
including any anime that I've included
in my top 20 Shonen videos to keep it a
little bit fresh so with that out of the
way let's get started right off the bat
then I want to talk about Golden kamui
excuse me
[Applause]
golden car movie really doesn't lend
itself much to seem like one of the
first names in your mind when talking
about mature anime it's not particularly
violent it doesn't have any mind-blowing
themes or the like but I don't think
anyone could just stumble into this
historical wartime drama and enjoy it as
easily as say the mainstream Shonen hits
golden gun movie takes things rather
deliberately sticking to its historical
fiction roots and its story of war and
survival despite that statement making
golden gun movies seem like a moody
dramatic show it does have its
light-hearted moments as well you know
just as how life is full of different
spices golden car movie explores history
and I know culture in a way that both
showcases the gritty aspects of survival
as well as heavier themes like PTSD
while showing off the comedic and
Whimsical aspects of a culture that
seems so far and different from our own
Golden Gun movie captures the mood of
what I pretty much Envision this list to
contain and I think the historical
fiction is a good way to kick things off
for this list
[Music]
up next we have a movie series garden of
sinners
let me talk nasu when we talk tight Moon
everyone thinks of the fight series but
don't worry we're gonna get to that one
soon first though I'd like to detour to
a series of movies that I feel deserves
a little bit more love garden of sinners
now if you've been a fan of Fate
specifically the mainline series with
Shiro saber Rin and the like you'll find
yourself at home in Garden of Sinners
it's the same universe and all but
that's not all this film series really
gives off the same urban fantasy
atmosphere with its slew of tragic
characters quite the emphasis on
dialogue and an overall gloomy move
supported by Magic while the face series
is more known for the fights and the
crazy Noble phantasms in the grand
moments Garden of Sinners does have a
more muted approach to things it's got
action but it's overall something more
philosophical and has mystery to it too
heck the movies themselves will require
the views to do a little bit of
detective work since they're not
released in chronological order too
regardless of that it constitutes as
part of the charm of it all and garden
of sinners is a series that will really
make you look Inward and ponder about
things for a bit before it blasts you
with some brilliant artwork animation as
expected from a set of UFO table films
this video sponsors Tokyo tree and
sakurako are two subscription boxes that
aim to bring you some of the best in
Japanese snacks and sweets or in the
Comforts of your home with Tokyo treat
you get up to 20 exclusive limited
edition and seasonal Japanese snacks and
for February Love Is in the Air as Tokyo
troop presents its Valentine's box with
an assortment of flavors ranging from
garai's spicy Ramen sour plum chips to
Lucky daifuku KitKat is bound to be
something for your precious ones taste
buds if you think the old school is cool
and you fancy the more traditional for
your loved ones say the more Artisan
types of snacks then we have sakurako
for you sakurako in contrast to Tokyo
tree offers snacks more along the lines
of good old Japanese tea Mochi and
provincial exclusives this time sakurako
is partnering with the ever Lively Osaka
area to bring you its very own take on
Valentine's I'm talking chocolate Mochi
strawberry dorayaki and much more of
course sakurako boxes come with their
kitchenware and this month you'll be
getting this pretty super it's very
handy don't you think don't forget to
use the code Vinnie and get five dollars
off your first box you can't get a
better Japanese experience in the
comfort of your own home than this so
don't forget to grab this opportunity
from magic fantasy we move on to sci-fi
now with VV
[Applause]
0 was a hard show to classify I think it
could count for this list and it has
action but I think it's really more of a
thriller mystery with the fights just
being extra spice however what does feel
more action dominated is DARPA
nagatsuki's other work Vivi I wasn't
sure what to make of Vivi before
watching it you know I was excited for
it sure because I like re-zero and want
more from the same Creator and I like my
action girls in sci-fi but besides that
there wasn't much in the way of
expectations when it was all said and
done what I witnessed can be summed up
as one of the best that 2021 had to
offer VB is a show that's simply filled
with astounding action sequences has an
amazing soundtrack and is overall just a
spectacle something you'd expect out of
a theatrical production except this is a
Sci-Fi TV series that also doubles as a
rather dark Thriller as expected of the
author all the while it differentiates
itself enough from the shows with
similarities like Steins Gate the word
of Vivi is easy to get acclimated to
it's got some quirky characters to root
for and it's quick for the show to take
you by the Reigns and just strap you in
for the ride a ride that's very
thematically beautiful I know thank him
but Vinnie none of those are real mature
you know the kind with the violence and
the blood and the stuff edgy teenage
boys absolutely lap up well then here's
Helsing Ultima for you
ah Helsing these kinds of shows never go
out of favor especially if you look at
the pre-season height for chainsaw man
you know brutal violent affairs with the
main character there's all sorts of
badass in battle while chainsaw man
incorporates some Modern elements of
Anime characters in Dengue like the
pervasion Alucard is all business oh and
he's way more overpowered too actually
back in the 2000s Alucard is pretty much
the embodiment of the badass flavor of
that era and his conquests are a thing
of Legend amongst anime fans Helsing the
Ryan that's just full of Thrills and
jaw-dropping action high octane Fast and
Furious if you're out for an adrenaline
rush I want to take a look at a
representation of a relatively recently
bygone era Helsing ultimate could be the
pick for you they just don't do shows
like this anymore now don't you think
thank you
if you want a similar Fair bit in the
form of a movie how about Vampire Hunter
D bloodlust
[Music]
we take on another action vampire Title
Here a movie this time though vampire
Hunter D's a dark fantasy film that came
out in the year 2000 as a much
anticipated follow-up to the 1985 film
The Series has had its time in the
Limelight back then and was one of the
most popular fantasy franchises at some
point bloodlust now the second film has
received a lot of praise for its
excellence in animation and sound
Direction all the while having an art
style that showed how the franchise
never missed a beat despite over a
decade gap between the films you want
action you want horror and you want it
all compressed in a film that you can
easily just hop into and enjoy well
Vampire Hunter D bloodlust could be your
jam it's also pretty nice that you don't
have to be a fan to enjoy the movie you
can just hop in and you'll have yourself
a fun time even if you've got no clue
whatsoever about the franchise coming in
Vampire Hunter D was widely praised for
his animation at the time which is a
fitting statement to mention because the
next title I want to feature also felt
like a Pioneer for its time too arjin
CG in anime is nothing new even when
origen came out however it seems that it
was around the 2010s when the anime
industry really started to embrace CG
not in short bursts or some characters
like Idol shows but full CG I'm talking
about that's the first thing that
strikes out when you take a single look
at Arjun much like Knights of cydonia or
arpeggio of blue steel before it but
that's not all there is in this series
it's an action Series where the fights
are good but also tactical it's also got
a dark backdrop that has a sprinkling of
philosophy and morality it's a pretty
gloomy and cynical series that helps us
examine our roles in relation to the
world around us and it's Denny's in well
I'm not perpetrating that you take
anything that these cynical shows teach
us about the world as gospel does make
you think of it doesn't it given that
this is a show that's for the more
mature audiences to fully appreciate
it's something worth your time provided
you remove any Prejudice with regards to
CG anime overall it's one of the
meaningful edgy shows out there if you
will foreign
stray dogs
[Music]
now bungo stray dogs is unique it does
the historical fiction thing and applies
it to authors making this a short Home
Run for the bibliophile side of the
anime Community or while wrapping it up
in an enjoyable mystery action series
that just keeps on getting better this
series turned out to be one of the
underrated gems of the 2010s this CNN
isn't unpopular by any means with
merchandise of Plenty in season after
season but it does seem that people talk
about it in too high regard however I
think that's got more to do with the
Target demographic now the overall
approach of the series doesn't lend
itself to a lot of crazy overpowered
moves that break the internet then again
nor does it open itself up to a lot of
those who would win the base that
breathe life into battle Shonen that's
why I called Boon go stray dogs
underrated for the amount of traction it
got it has all the ways to keep up with
the big seasonal hits with its great
balance of Comedy mystery and action in
fact I still have the final fight of the
Season ranked up high in there as one of
my favorite final battles to an arc you
do have to know though that this show is
an investment in time it takes quite a
while to ramp up but when it does the
arc climaxes are simply rewarding
okay so it's time for a video game
adaptation to Grace the list now with
cyberpunk Edge runners
with a lot of video game adaptation
stepping up recently it's not surprising
that cyberpunk edge Runners ended up
being the way it did we already got a
glimpse of the potential of the more
mainstream more Normie game worlds being
turned into series with Arcane and
cyberpunk Edge Runners Builds on that
momentum quite a bit actually well we've
got a lot of these cyberpunk titles
focusing more on the implications of
Technology intertwining with Humanity
cyberpunk Edge Runners decides to go the
other way and relish in the technology
the explosions and the flashiness of it
all rule of cool as they say with that
being said it's not that the show is
some dumb action flick or something like
that it's quite the opposite actually
and you get that once you reach the
Midway point so it's pretty much the
versatility of it that makes such a
popular series that's attracted fans
from all sides of the spectrum those who
love their explosions and those who love
their mature themes
okay
we move on from one sci-fi hit to
another the ever popular psycho pass
[Music]
[Applause]
reflects the world that's become closer
to our own by the day for something that
came out in the early 2010s it sure did
quite a hell of a job for telling the
Future For Better or Worse this is a
utopian world where people's thoughts
and reason have been integrated into the
Civil system a means of objectively
quantifying someone's inclination to
crime and determining a citizen's Threat
Level we follow Argan a tsunamori and
shinyakogami a Duo who in their quest to
uphold Justice begin uncovering the
Civil system for what it really is
perhaps in this world such an objective
system an almost dystopian one could
actually be flawed and corrupt released
in 2012 Psycho-Pass continues gien
urobuchi's role of masterful writing
following both Fate Zero and madoga
Magicka as it examines some hard-eating
questions like what Justice really is
truly is something that's become more
pronounced in the recent news cycle and
it's amazing how an anime from a decade
ago can still speak to us on this level
great action a lot of questions in the
backdrop for us to answer and an
exhilarating Pace makes psycho pass a
winner in my book
coming in as the 10th entry on the list
is summertime render
we've had time travel and time Loop
stories and Anime are plenty however I
think that a few of them have captured
the mystery aspect and integrated with
such high octane action as perfectly as
Summertime render did short the thing
turned into an action thread at the
halfway point but it never lost sight of
its roots as it started out as a murder
mystery even when the tone shifted to
the humans fighting back as more secrets
were unraveled and more Mysteries kept
getting thrown at you and the best part
of it is that you feel like you've got
an active role in finding the clues and
coming up with the theories there's so
much involvement with summertime renders
mystery and there's a real connection
that gets formed with the characters in
the audience everything caps off with
one insane action finale that could put
some purely action shows to shame and
again ending that truly feels earned I'm
not going to elaborate any further on
this one and I'll just do the best thing
I can do and tell you to watch it
seriously it's an anime of the Year
Contender for 2022 and if you're
enjoying this video please hit that like
button I'd really appreciate it if we've
talked about cyberpunk then why not
Ghost in the Shell
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah how can we leave out one of The
Originators of the genre in terms of
anime as I mentioned a while ago
cyberpunk Edge Runners is the one that
relishes in the core factor of sci-fi
meanwhile Ghost in the Shell while
having no shortage of action has a More
Meek and serious approach to things sure
the fighting and the excitement are
there with this being a show featuring
special ops hackers and a lot of what
you can call the Staples of the genre
but I feel the Ghost in the Shell really
shines in the complexity of his story
yeah I'd say that it takes on a more
reflective you know a more mature look
at it in order to fully appreciate what
the series has to offer yes you can
enjoy it as an action show but I feel
that the message would be incomplete
without looking at the themes in depth
the dialogue and the like Ghost in the
Shell is a classic that's held up even
to this day one of the Pioneers in the
genre it wouldn't hurt to give it a
watch and see how it influenced the
sub-genre even to this day
an isakai hit makes the list now and
it's mushoku tensei
[Laughter]
now I did say in the introduction that I
was going to mostly avoid anime that are
classified as mature by the way of the
more sexual themes but I think we can
give mushoku tensei a slight pass in now
can't we after all with the show as
influential as this and as solid in
terms of World building and character
growth how can it not be one of the top
recommendations here and it's not like
it's simply a popcorn fest with
simplistic arcs like a lot more of the
fan service he shows and the other
issakai there's a reason why mushoku
tensei has stood the test of time and
retained a good reputation in the anime
sphere at least to those who didn't mind
its questionable themes so with that
being said mushoku tensei isn't a show
for everyone like I said it did
influence the isakai genre and that
includes pretty much everything stuff
that people love the genre for and stuff
that are easy bait for detractors to
pylon you get the complete package with
mushoku tensei but Brave the elements
and you'll find an ambitious story of
growth and Adventure set in one of the
more wonderful worlds crafted in modern
Japanese fiction
however if you're up for Carnage and
find modern fantasy way too colorful and
idealistic for your liking and you might
want to dive into the world of Berserk
in a way you know berserk does feel like
the antithesis of mushoku tensei and
pretty much a lot of elements of modern
anime that detract his sight in berserk
the show's violent and manly and it's
dark and cynical so if you're up for a
show that's edgy in that way berserk
could be your calling however it's not
all about the violence and the Darkness
in berserk after all something that's
only Edge wouldn't stand the test of
time as well as the series did berserk
for its time is a masterpiece on the
part of production great music great
voice acting in a world that really fits
its tune all attached to a compelling
story of a vagabond in search of Revenge
don't let the outdated art style fool
you though berserk is truly one of the
more mature anime that deserves to be
labeled a classic and make sure you do
everyone a favor and watch the older
ones the 2016 one was very popular for
all the wrong reasons
foreign
right now it's time for some mood
Whiplash again from the dreary world of
berserk we go to heroville with one
punch man
granted I feel that one punch man is a
fringe example of a mature anime it's
classified as a Saiyan instead of a
Shonen but its premise and its World
lends itself to one of the many colorful
universes that wouldn't look out of
place in a jump shown him if you're out
for watching a parody anime one punch
man is the one to look out for because
it goes beyond just parodying Anime
tropes setting the comedic tone aside
you'll find a wonderfully written show
that deserves every bit of popularity
that it's got you know for me the most
enjoyable part of one punch man is
actually its cast of characters the
brilliant group of heroes and villains
all make an impact in overt ways it's
easy to pick favorites because there are
just so many characters to like and they
easily make Impressions that last even
if their screen time is so minuscule in
terms of anime standards in between the
action we also get a whole lot of
memorable moments to get you both hyped
and heartbroken one after another and
all of this is backed up with top tier
animation and music so you've got
yourself a winner
bakano is up next and it's been a while
since I've heard that name
[Music]
I wouldn't doubt it if you told me that
you've never watched bakano It's a niche
anime that stood out with how it
seemingly defied all those Anime
conventions back in the late 2000s and
Orthodox like one punch man buckano
strength lies in its characters everyone
from Isaac and miria to Lad Russo all
come with their own charms and while
some may lack in development due to the
one call run of the show they'll remain
charismatic and help carry the narrative
that takes quite a while to get used to
they've all got their individual stories
too given some of them ample development
bacano feels weird but in a good way and
it's not likely to be a show that can be
enjoyed as much by the typical casual
viewer however if you want to change
your pace and watch something that
looked unique and different from Modern
anime then bakano could be worth a shot
and how can we talk about bacano without
mentioning its cousin durarara
foreign
style same colorful Ensemble of
characters coming from the respective
countries underworld durarara and bakano
are shows that seem Inseparable in
association if you like one you're
probably gonna like the other in
contrast to the muted tones of the
prohibition era however durarara takes
us to the bustling neighborhood of
ikebukuro where craziness seems to come
every other moment durarara relies more
on the rule of cool and his overall much
bigger and louder and I think that works
to its benefit it does seem to be the
more attractive show to watch and once
you're in you get treated to an
unconventional narrative style wife with
mature themes and is very rich in
character arcs while the question of
whether the characters do develop is
something that could spark debate
there's no question that they all make
an impact durarara is a show that stands
well enough alone and it does have
sequels to keep you occupied if you
enjoyed the series
foreign
[Music]
it isn't hard to see why either actually
it's got a lot of things going for it
the dark plot compelling characters the
mature themes the violence in a level
that's not typical of a jump series The
Amazing production quality and the
horror elements that glue people to
their seats from the outset it carved
out a niche for itself and it strongly
caters to people in that Niche I don't
think he had as strong as a reception as
say the more traditional Shonen like
Demon Slayer or Jiu Jitsu Kaizen because
of how r18 it is both in World Views and
themes and the actual visual content
still if you're in its target market and
relishing what it brings to the table
the anime adaptation of Chainsaw man is
more than serviceable if you want no
holes barred Full Throttle action all
while keeping up with the modern anime
community and what's hot it's never too
late to get started on chainsaw man
body horror Galore continues in this
next show parasite uh
ah a classic indeed parasite ended up
being one of my favorite shows in the
mid-2010s but it didn't seem that way at
first you know honestly didn't know what
to make of this adaptation of a horror
manga from the late 80s to early 90s but
I did get more than what I bargained for
when I found myself lost in the gripping
story The non-stop action and the
developing bond between man and host
Shinji and migi's bond is truly a beauty
to watch develop but parasite also holds
up really well with other themes as well
sure it can get a little bit preachy at
times with its environmental
implications and negative outlook on
humans but you can't help but think that
those themes do make sense once you take
a step back and take a look at the world
as it is now I also like how it stuck
onto those themes all the way to the end
given us a show that has no shortage of
action but is also thematically
consistent and strong if you missed out
on the show I highly implore trying out
parasite it fits in a very good
narrative in the span of 24 episodes and
you'll definitely have a great time with
it
Jesus
as we approach the end of the list I
don't want to leave out my anime of the
year for 2019 villain Saga
Finland Saga I think is one of the most
complete anime I've ever watched and
that's surprisingly though coming from
historical fiction but it just has all
the important elements of a show caught
in a great balance I'm talking action
World building drama complex characters
it's got it all Finland Saga is a show
that I can truly recommend to people not
into anime thanks to how mature and
competent it is yeah it wouldn't prepare
them when they eventually hop into stuff
like say isakai or cute girl Slice of
Life or School anime but for something
that can ease these kinds of people into
the medium Vinland Saga would be it
doubly so if the person's into history
Finland Saga while fictional for the
most part of it crafts a wonderful world
that masterfully shows off what the
world of Vikings was like back then a
cruel world you know filled with Wars
drama and despair but not one without
hope is evident with the rich colors
that fill up the Landscapes of Europe
it's an engaging tale of survival that
combines both action and a meaningful
Narrative of politics love war and
Redemption finally let's end the list
with another all-time favorite of mine
Fate Zero
the Fate series has gone through a lot
of incarnations over the years however
what I think is narratively the most
mature and strongest among them is none
other than Fate Zero the main Fate
series in the grand order anime have
their strong suits and I highly
recommend them as much as Fate Zero
however zero automatically qualifies for
the list more due to its themes and how
it's not afraid to go off in the deep
end showing off the less glamorous side
of Storytelling you've got characters
who are heroes in the marginal sense of
the world a lot of betrayal and Foul
Play and a story where it seems like the
good guys don't always win in the end
it's not afraid to tell the story as is
and for every empty Victory his sense of
anticipation only grows as you can't
wait to find out what's next phase zero
is truly a show that you can make the
most out of by stepping back and
thinking yeah it is fun to watch your
favorite Noble phantasms in play and
it's even more fun watching Gilgamesh in
his prime just owning everyone but the
fights are barely the true focus of the
series this is an ubw or fgo that's the
more philosophical approach that is
indeed zero to many fans and non-fans
alike and that's also why it's what I
feel to be the best the Fate series has
been in anime form
that's a lot isn't it 20 titles for you
to enjoy and hope that you like my list
if you've got more shows to recommend
that fit the bill feel free to let me
know so that we can compare our lists if
you stayed until the end then I thank
you very much for that I really hope to
see you again so make sure to drop a
little like and a subscription that's it
for today and I'll see you next time